- All right, this is
Vandaveon and Mike here.
"The Vandaveon and Mike Show."
We have a little subtitle
for this mug.
- Almost said colon.
Colon--pooh!
Popped your O-ring.
[laughter]
- He said, "O-ring"!
We talking about the new
"Van and Mike Show."
It's called "Van and Mike:
the Ascension."
- It's a mindset.
- And it's a--what?
- It is a mindset, man.
- Things have been taking place.
There have been some
seismic shifts and whatnot
in our career.
- We made it.
- In the upwards way.
- And the crowning achievement
is that "Key & Peele"
have finally hired us
on the show
as writers and whatnot.
- "Key & Peele."
- To do the thing
we were bornt to do.
- I knew they had some sense.
- So, finally,
they hired us up, right?
So we collaborating
with them now.
And I tell you, man,
it was a real good fit,
because, like, two weeks in,
they had given us nicknames
and whatnot.
So they was calling us--
what is it, what is it?
- P.A.
- P.A.s, P.A.s, right?
Which was like a nickname
for...
"Pen assassins."
- "Pen assassins."
That's what we feel.
- We pen assassins, man,
'cause we just murdering up
that comedy right now.
- Blip-blip-blip-blip-blip.
- You know, like...
I be using some ninja pens
up in here.
Soo-swah!
Soo-sway-sway!
Swipe!
- Penis style.
- [laughs]
Penis style.
[exhaling sharply]
[laughter]
You got to give it to me!
- Get the fuck
out of here.
- Oh, my God, man.
We had a lot of fun
on the shoot, though.
So, what we gonna do is,
we had signed these
confidentiality agreements.
It allows us to confide
in the audience,
the material
that's behind the scenes.
So we can tell you anything
we want about the show
prior to the show coming out.
So right now,
what you gonna see
is Mike having
a brainstorming session.
- A meeting of minds.
- A meeting of minds,
as you will.
So that's what happened
with Mike.
We gonna show you some of this
right now here.
- Yo, what's up?
- Hi.
- It's me, Mike.
- Who?
I'm sorry.
Have we met before?
I'm sorry, I don't know
if we've met before.
- I'm the new P.A.
- Oh, new P.A.,
hey, how you doing, Mike?
Nice to meet you, man, yeah.
You and who?
- Vandaveon.
- Van--what?
Vandaveon?
- Yeah, we sent some videos
the past couple years.
Now we P.A.s, so we could feed
you, like, lines or whatever.
- Oh, yeah, that's okay.
We got the script supervisor
to do that.
- No, really, it's no sweat.
- No, I appreciate it.
But the script supervisor,
it's just,
it's her job and stuff.
- I was thinking maybe
in this sketch,
you could like, you know,
when somebody slaps ass,
like, you could
make a fart sound.
That could, like,
enhance the comedy,
'cause you already
got asses in there.
- I will...
I will take that
under advisement, yeah.
Can you do me
a favor, actually?
Could you go--
there are supplements
that are in my trailer,
and they're red.
They're in a bottle
called Omega Krill.
- I don't know
nothing about that.
- No, I'm just telling you
where to go.
- Listen, listen.
In this brainstorming
session,
it sounded like, you know,
there was some,
what they call in the business,
chuffa, okay?
You're talking about getting
him krill,
you know, like, squid pills
and whatnot, right?
- Well, you break the ice
with an anecdote.
- With an anec--yeah, right,
that's what he did.
But what you did miss in that
interaction particularly
is all of the scene ideas
that would come out of that,
like "Fart Dick."
- "Fart Supplements."
- "Fart Supplements,"
that's a good scene,
where you just take
particular supplements,
and they just make you fart.
- "Sigmord Ford."
- We have a whole scene
called "Sigmoid Freud."
It's a colon that got a beard.
It smoke a cigar.
- That was--
- Just like Sigmund Freud!
Because our shit
is smart, though.
- "Urethra Franklin."
- "Urethra Franklin"?
[laughing]
That's--
- "Who's Afraid
of Vagina Woolf?"
[laughter]
- I got to walk it off!
Hold up a second.
I just got to
walk it off a second.
That shit's comedy gold
right there, man.
Do you have anything
you want to say about that?
- When you start
riffing with someone...
- Yeah.
- You synergize...
- You synergize,
right, right.
- With their brain.
So, in some ways,
half my brain
is now
Keegan Michael Key's brain.
- You see,
this is the kind of insight
that you ain't get on any other
kind of Internet shows.
We gonna move into
another clip right now.
Okay, because of these
confidentiality agreements
we have signed, we're about
to straight up show you
some, like, straight up
confidential stuff,
behind the scenes,
never-seen-before footage.
And the best part,
it's all completely legal
for us to show it to you.
- This is one
of their better sketches,
I think because we were present.
- I think it has something to do
with us being in the room.
- It's a sequel
to "Slap-Ass."
- "Slap-Ass 1."
So we gonna go to some footage
right now
from a scene that's
gonna be in the show.
Y'all gonna love it.
It's gonna be informative.
You are now learning
from the masters, Van and Mike.
- And...action.
- Everybody, I need your
attention right now, okay?
I know some of you guys
were not here
when Rafi was here, okay.
We don't want to trigger him
with any slap-ass.
- Good game, man.
- These dudes need
to stop scooting back.
They should let that dude
get in there
and get that ass,
is what they should do.
- You should yell that line
when it come up.
- What?
- You should yell that line.
- Good game, man.
- You can slap me.
You can slap me
in the ass.
- Shh!
- Who's shushing me?
- Who's shushing?
- Don't shush us.
- So thank you very much,
from both me, Van, and Mike.
You want to say
something, Mike?
- What do you say
to people who don't know
what the inside
of Hollywood looks like?
- You say, stay tuned,
because we're going
to educate you, all right?
- You see those two
new guys?
The guy with
the fucking Rick Ross beard?
- Weird.
- Well, clearly he's ambitious,
because it's
pretty well groomed,
so that takes
a certain amount of effort.
And the other guy
with the dreads,
with the tiny dreads...
- That guy...
he was talking
while we were shooting.
- Oh, I know.